your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
excellencies laureates ladies and
gentlemen let me start with a question
why did Newton's Apple fall to the
ground
because physics comes first here I will
start with the answer from the
physicists there is a force called
gravity that exists between any two
objects with a magnitude proportional to
the product of the object's masses and
inversely proportional to the square of
the distance between the Centers of the
masses the Apple is therefore propelled
by this force towards the center of the
earth when it leaves the tree now we
will move to the answer from the
evolutionary biologist once upon a time
apples used to go in all directions
up down sideways the world was full of
ricocheting apples however only those
apples that fell to the ground were able
to germinate and grow new trees
[Music]
and of course over millions of years the
forces of evolution selected for those
which fell to the ground which is why
apples now fall to the ground now we are
three chemists who shamelessly
expropriated from physics and biology
including their terrible jokes to create
molecules for the common good we share
deep admiration for evolution a force of
nature that has led to the finest
chemistry of all time and to all living
things on this planet the fuel for
evolution as you well know is diversity
with natural selection leading to the
continuous adaptations and improvements
in nature's handiwork organisms and
organizations without this diversity are
doomed to extinction in a rapidly
changing world you think of this Nature
has explored only a tiny fraction of the
life and life's molecules that are
possible with evolution in our hands
with the ability to set genetic
diversity and tailor the forces of
selection we can now explore paths that
nature has left unexplored we can also
explore paths that nature will never
explore we can select life and there
chemistry's to our benefit to create new
sources of energy to fix the carbon in
our atmosphere to cure disease to make
us younger more beautiful or we can make
new weapons of terror or state control
which shall it be the lesson from our
Apple joke
in practice and in theory evolution is
all too easy to apply incorrectly and so
on behalf of all three laureates in
chemistry George Smith sir Gregory
winter and myself who's recombined
messages evolved in tonight's toast I
propose a toast to evolution may we use
it well thank you
[Applause]
[Music]